hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen and
today I'm watching the classic the film
classic from 1990 Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles I don't have a very complicated
tapestry to unwind about my relationship
with the Ninja Turtles I can remember
watching a few episodes here and there
of the cartoon series growing up but
I've never seen a Ninja Turtles movie
and I was never like a giant fan of them
I bought this dress specifically for
this reaction and I would have to say
that my favorite one is the purple one I
don't know his name but I just like the
color purple I don't I have seen some
reference photos from these first
original three films and they look
pretty hilarious but then I saw the
photos of the turtles from the Michael
Bay right he directed those the new ones
and those look like terrible demon
monsters so I don't really know which
ones are good which ones aren't good
very excited to jump into this first one
though today cowabunga
[Music]
I mean it was fun the giant clunky weird
costumes and like puppetry in this film
I thought was gonna throw me for a loop
I thought it wasn't going to to work for
me but it ended up really working for me
the fights in those suits are honestly
pretty okay and really decent
considering they're in these giant huge
buff turtles let's juice the turtles
themselves like the characters of the
turtles there wasn't a lot going on
there other than them saying like cool
90s terms and like late 80s radical
things but it's pretty good
pretty fun it's fun in a very campy way
I had a very good time watching it I
think that April Emil was stunning I
loved her character in this she was very
much who I imagined April O'Neil would
be in a movie about Ninja Turtles from
what I've heard and from what I hear
Megan Fox was not the character that was
written for her was not a newer one this
was like she was just she nailed it in
this
I loved Casey Jones I thought he was
such a fun character a really good
addition to the Turtles
in April I think they needed that one
other human there to kind of hope with
kind of the awkward dialogue that the
turtles had overall I loved the
characters shredder is hilarious I knew
shredders name before this but it's such
like a late 80s Early 90s like skater
village shredder Master Splinter was
wonderful his puppet was hilarious I
love rats so I was super into split day
you open on April Emil telling the news
and it's about these crimes that are
happening with no suspect it's called
like the silent crimes or whatever and
she's like the most silent thing though
he's a silence coming from City Hall
girl oh I love it but then the very
magazine is her walking to her car and
she sees a rat and she goes ballistic
like she freaks out it's like great I
know that this is most likely
foreshadowing for what's coming with
Master Splinter
but it was a little much there were
times definitely when she risen a lot
but I mean this is a movie about four
turtles who trudged themselves into like
toxic slime and then became Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles so all right
overacting warranted I suppose then oh
my gosh okay so April's getting herself
real deep in bad guys because she's
reporting on it and they find her in
this empty doubt train station she's
waiting for a train no one else is there
and the bad guy comes up to her and says
something that Doug and Rob Walker say a
lot to each other
and I've never known what it was from
and I get it now I get the reference I
am here to deliver a message so she
finally meets splinter and the turtles
it's really cute they are now staying at
her place in the city above her antique
shop because she owns like an entire
city block it's a new city that's like
maybe the most unrealistic thing about
this entire movie that then you finally
get to see the bad guy layer which is
just like a 90s kid hangout heaven it's
really funny I was like skateboarding
inside they're like playing poker
cigarettes I'm pretty sure that's Sam
Rockwell's it's like the lead one of the
lead bad guys for just a scene really
funny okay I see you there
Sam Rockwell's game your start and you
see shredder for the first time and I
just wrote oMG shredder love the look
basically it's just back and forth
between the foot gang and the turtles
biting each other and trying to take
back the city of New York so the foot
gang comes over to April's apartment
where the turtles are at and sets it all
on fire and her place is ruined I really
do enjoy one part in this though she
gets fired while her place is on fire
and it's just absolute chaos and then
she's also getting fired on the phone I
thought that was it was a clever way to
do it splinter had been taken from them
that's why the turtles were staying in
her apartment and I just realized that
he's still missing by this book and
they're really not doing that much to
try and find splinter and he's like this
gentle old Rach like go save him go save
your rat grandpa go it made me a little
sad honestly the Splinter was like
hanging there
the bad guys lair he's such a sweet old
grandpa rat ninja we all know one we all
have one in our lives because April
house was set on fire in New York they
go to this giant farmhouse outside
probably upstate New York you own a lot
of property my friend good for you so
the turtles are like I mean maybe we
should find splinter and then they
meditate him into being and splinters
like I'm so proud of you goodbye
they're like oh I guess we should
probably I was so just this first
splinter they go back and Danny or Billy
or Chad or whoever helps splinter and
the turtles by Trenor there are a lot of
fights in this film it's just like same
scene fight scene scene fight scene
scene fight scene scene fight and which
what else are you expecting in the Ninja
Turtles movie nothing but I was
surprised at how well the fights looked
and it was like a fun thing to watch the
fights when they're in these giant
costumes animatronic heads right isn't
it there there's people in the costumes
but the heads are like also at the same
time moving there's like a lot of
components in this and the fights
honestly didn't look as bad as I thought
they were gonna look they were they were
pretty cool
Danny runs up to the dad is like dad and
the dad's like I've missed you so much
you've been gone not everywhere looking
for you where have you been and the kid
just goes it's dad now dad such a random
thing like I really had to go search my
soul and then I met these mutant turtles
and I I joined this gang with this like
ninja warrior named shredder and I was
like living with him and I
in the sewers and I really you know what
I found out that extra end and the why
now for me damn Casey and April kiss it
was cute I love it I don't know I didn't
imagine that there was any like April
O'Neil and turtle action going on I hope
there wasn't and there wasn't all right
and I just wrote my dream is for a ninja
master rat to say cowabunga to me in the
credits there's a rap and it was amazing
they were once normal but now they're
mutants splinters the teacher so they
are the students Leonardo Michelangelo
and Donatello make up the team with one
other fellow Raphael boy they sure say
damn a lot you really do it was honestly
darker than I thought it was going to be
and I liked that predictions you won't
like it and I'll never forgive you for
it I then like it looks like you got it
bring it you'll be surprised at how only
one of these New York raised Turtles has
a New York accent uh yeah what the hell
is that why why they're their voices are
real weird to me I know that Corey
Feldman right it's one of them I guess
overall if I had to go back and pick my
favorite from the film it would be the
orange one not the purple one Donatello
bright is the purple one
Michelangelo is next week I'm coming
back with the sequel of this number two
thank you again so much for watching I
really appreciate it I'll see you all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
you